messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
pour évoquer ces manifestations contre
le pass sanitaires alors un total de 175
mille cinq cent trois personnes ont
manifesté dont quatorze mille sept cents
à paris selon le ministère de
l'intérieur à 19 heures ont recensé 220
manifestations dans tout le pays loïc
bonnets jaunes dirige vers vous on va
commencer avec vous elle la
participation elle est un petit peu et
légèrement en baisse aujourd'hui est ce
que cela signifie que pas sanitaires
commencent à être acceptés
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est ce
qui se passe dans nos établissements moi
j'ai un théâtre qui est ouvert à rouen
ce soir et à 110 personnes dans la salle
les gens sortent sont heureux vienne
rigoler je suis pas
philosophiquement pour le pass annie
terre parce que nous sommes des lieux
encore une fois mais on l'a dit redit on
est des lieux on doit accepter tout le
monde des blancs des noirs des hétéros
des homos des femmes des hommes enfin
voilà on a on est pas on n'est pas on
n'est pas là pour fliquer ou dire
n'entrez pas ou rentrer en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'avec les chiffres
que l'on a aujourd'hui les 22000 cas par
jour si on n'avait pas le pass and it et
on se référe mais les salariés qui
seraient derrière sont derrière moi
actuellement seraient au chômage partiel
les gens ne sait pas dans la salle les
comédiens seraient au chômage et des
gens n'auraient pas de divertissement
mais ça en laisse dehors moi je suis pas
encore une fois pour se passe à lithaire
mais force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui on est ouverts alors que
avec des chiffres comme aujourd'hui on
serait fermé s'il n'existait pas c'est
un éternel débat arnaud benedetti est ce
que selon vous le passez à iter est le
seul moyen pouvoir contrôler cette
épidémie tout en permettant finalement
un retour à la vie normale
pas sanitaire pose de problème il pose
d'abord un problème qui un problème de
principe concernant les libertés
publiques et d'égalité le conseil
constitutionnel a tranché mais c'est une
décision d'opportunité politique de plus
qu'une décision qu'il est fondée
juridiquement mais c'est ainsi que ça
s'est passé l'autre sujet c'est
l'efficacité du pas salutaire et on voit
bien que dans les mobilisations auxquels
nous faisons face aujourd'hui depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines c'est dans
la question des libertés que la question
du principe de l'efficacité du passé
inquiet poser en la matière alors
aujourd'hui on voit bien que le
gouvernement a fait ce choix
essentiellement non pas pour stocker
pour contenir l'épidémie mais bien
évidemment pour pousser les plus
récalcitrants à aller se faire vacciner
la finalité du pass sanitaire c'est de
faire adhérer à la maxi nations celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
allés se faire vacciner parce que
l'exécutif compte l'exécutif dans le
monde considère que la vaccination et la
porte de sortie de cette épidémie alors
avec quand même un bémol parce que
aujourd'hui on croyait que le discours
sur la vaccination a changé il y a
quelques mois on nous disait que de dose
suffirait que on voit qu'aujourd'hui il
va certain nombre de responsables
sanitaires sont en train de nous
expliquer qu'il faudra vraisemblablement
une troisième tendance voire peut-être
une quatrième dose donc le vrai sujet
dans les trois mois qui viennent dans
les quatre mois qui viennent ce sera la
question de l'efficacité de la
couverture vaccinale et c'est un hors
jeu qui est à l'enjeu qui n'est pas
propre gouvernement français qui propre
à tous les gouvernements qui sont
confrontées aujourd'hui à cette épidémie
loïc boon est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec les propos d'arnaud benedetti
oui
moi je vais vous raconter une anecdote
j'ai des collègues qui ont des
restaurants et des bars dans rouen qui
sont vaccinés qui demande le pass annie
terre et qui vont quand même manifester
donc cesser c'est vous dire à quel point
on est on est entre les deux en fait on
ne sait on sait le poids on sait plus
vraiment comment faire c'est à dire que
on préfère avoir nos établissements
ouverts avec un parce que fermer
complètement mais par contre ce que je
veux dire au jeune homme que j'ai
entendu dans votre reportage juste avant
qui disait moi je boycotte tous les
lieux qui demandent de passer ni terre
d'abord c'est en est contrainte de
demander c'est la loi donc c'est dommage
de nous faire payer ça à nous aller
manifester devant l'elysée ça y'a pas de
problème et nous on n'y est pour rien
voilà en l'occurrence on est obligé de
le faire sinon se prend une amende vous
savez quand vous êtes responsable quand
vous êtes dirigeant bas d'un bar d'un
restaurant d'un théâtre vous êtes
responsable de tout d'un incendie d'un
projecteur qui tombent ou d'impartialité
demandez donc quand j'entends cette
personne qui dit je boycotte et qui le
demandaient ils sont dans la rue avec
vous ils manifestent avec vous contre se
passe mais c'est vrai que quand on est
dans nos établissements on est contraint
de le demander voilà c'était le message
que je voulais passer c'est qu'on n'est
pas forcément pour mais on est obligé de
le faire aujourd'hui c'est la réalité
justement loïc bonnet et je pense que
vous n'êtes pas le premier a prononcé
ces mots vous l'avais dit il ya quelques
instants notre rôle c'est pas de fliquer
finalement les manifestants qu'on a
entendu aujourd'hui tous sont assez
méfiant par rapport à ceux se passe
tanit et est ce que vous comprenez cette
méfiance
je le comprends mais vous savez en est
fliqué depuis bien longtemps avec les
téléphones portables avec nos cartes
bleues avec les gps avec on est connecté
partout donc je suis pas sûr franchement
à titre personnel la banque pour le coup
c'est mon avis je suis pas sûr que je
suis plus fliquer avec un qr code
qu'avec tous les les autres systèmes
quand je vais dans un endroit que je
paye par carte on sait que je suis donc
ça c'est à mon avis une fausse ça veut
pas dire que je dénigre tous les autres
arguments mais cet argument là pour moi
il n'existe pas franchement on est déjà
assez flic est comme ça et dans ces cas
là il faut pas utiliser de carte bleue
pas de téléphone portable vous vous êtes
géolocalisé en deux secondes non c'est
pas forcément un argument pour moi mais
c'est vraiment moi c'est ce qui m'embête
le plus moi dans tout ça c'est la
division en fait on divise les gens et
ça c'est terrible parce que dans nos
lieux ce n'est que du divertissement or
un restaurant c'est du plaisir et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai cent dix
personnes dans ma salle mais ça a pris
beaucoup plus de temps il a fallu
montrer les qr code est par contre ce
que je peux vous dire en retour
d'expérience et que j'avais peur d'avoir
des commandes ird et des gens qui
s'énervent un peu j'ai aucun problème
les gens qui viennent ils savent qu'il
faut le montrer le montre avec plaisir
ils sont contents de venir et de rigoler
quand il sort de la salle ils ont passé
une heure et demie à oublier leurs
problèmes ça c'est un c'est un vrai
soulagement pour nous de pouvoir rester
ouverts arnaud benedetti est ce que vous
comprenez cette méfiance dont font
parler les manifestants au fil des au
fil des samedis finalement
écoutez moi je comprends pas qu'ils ont
du moment où on touche un des principes
qui sont des principes fondamentaux qui
fondent au régime depuis des décennies
voire des siècles qu'il y ait un débat
autour de cette question pour moi c'est
un débat qui est très noble de
satellites s'interroger sur les
conséquences d'un état d'urgence dont on
dit qu'ils soient petits consentira en
principe du pass anitea fusion prend le
texte de la loi à partir du 15 novembre
mais on est dans un tel état
d'incertitude et le début de cette
épidémie finalement tout ce qui a été
dit a tellement été affirmé par les
faits et par la dynamique de l'épidémie
qu il est naturel que dans un contexte
d'aussi grandes incertitudes les gens se
posent des questions qui me paraissent
tout à fait légitime d'autant plus que
les scientifiques le qui eux aussi tu
attendes sont en train parfois de se
contredire donc il ya là me semble-t-il
des interrogations des enjeux qui sont
tout à fait légitimes et la grande
erreur serait vraisemblablement de
considérer que les gens qui aujourd'hui
se mobilisent contre le pass sanitaires
sont tous des obscurantistes voir des
gens peu équipiers voire fort mais je
crois que il ya aujourd'hui un débat un
débat démocratique et que d'une certaine
manière l'exécutif serait en tout cas
bien intentionnés d'entendre ce que dit
la ville d'autant plus qu'on est face à
un bo qui malgré tout est encore
s'installer dans la bulle et on est au
coeur de l'été on voit que quand même
les mobilisations reste importante reste
massy même si apparemment une petite
décrue aujourd'hui et on peut d'ailleurs
s'interroger aussi sur les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur donc on peut
aujourd'hui entendre
est-ce que vous pensez justement ça peut
reprendre à la rentrée
de plus belle c'est extrêmement
difficile de le dire il y aura vraiment
d'autres paramètres qui peuvent
permettre une agrégation la france est
un pays qui est fracturée on a vu lors
de la crise et gilet jaune donc les
colères qui sont des colères sociales
qui sont des colères culturelles qui
sont des couleurs politiques ils sont
parfois on sait des colères terribles
territoriales elles peuvent se réaliser
à tout moment donc il ya en effet un
risque que cette mobilisation prenne
d'autres formes à la rentrée en fonction
du contexte ce que joue aujourd'hui bien
évidemment à l'exécutif ce le fait que
l'opinion publique finissent quand vous
l'avez 10 en début de débat par
s'accommoder de une situation qu'elle
considère comme un pis-aller transitoire
louis bonnet vous êtes au contact direct
des clients vous leur parlez est ce que
vous pensez que cette situation avec ce
pass sanitaires notamment l et nabeul
sur plusieurs semaines peut-être
plusieurs mois comment est-ce que vous
aujourd'hui vous voyez l'avenir
moi très sincèrement j'espère que ça va
durer le moins de temps possible et tous
les gens le disent aujourd'hui ils
viennent ils sont vaccinés donc ils ont
le pass mais quoi qu'il arrive c'est
vrai que tous les jours et toute la
journée j'ai des coups de téléphone pour
savoir s'ils peuvent venir s'ils peuvent
pas venir j'ai eu ma deuxième dose il ya
trois jours et ce que je vois là c'est
c'est ingérable mais ce que j'aimerais
dire aussi est vraiment c'est très
important de le signaler tous les
patrons de bars les salariés de théâtre
de restaurants vivent de ça donc si vous
refermez ces lieux si vous n'avez pas de
pass and it rs qu'il le faut ça c'est un
autre débat mais si vous fermez tous ces
lieux gelée de quoi en vie c'est ça
aussi le problème vraiment et quand
j'entends encore une fois on va
boycotter ces lieux moi je veux savoir
ce que font ces gens qui boycotte ces
lieux parce que si eux ils ont lu
travail ils ont de la chance nous on en
a pas sinon lieu ferme on est privé 1 on
n'a pas de subvention n'a pas des dons
n'est pas voilà donc demain vous fermer
nos établissements on a plus de salaires
donc c'est c'est une vraie question
aussi et je peux vous dire que
moralement ça fait quoi qu'il arrive du
bien de retravailler parce que moi j'ai
des collègues je suis président d'une
association de théâtre on est 80 théâtre
en france il ya des théâtres qui n'ont
pas encore ouvert depuis le 29 octobre
et qui vont rouvrir la au mois de
septembre vous rendez compte ça va faire
presque un an qu'ils ne font rien que ce
sont des gens qui ont investi leur
argent qu'ils ont leur société et qui
moralement ont mis tout leur coeur tous
leurs patients qui ne font rien de leur
vie donc
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
moi j'ai des maux du monde dans ma salle
et quand on se bat dans roue il ya des
gens dans les restaurants je dis pas que
c'est une solution encore une fois je
suis contre ce pass sanitaire mais
aujourd'hui j'espère ça va durer le
moins longtemps possible un an benedetti
on s'approche à grand pas 2
l'élection présidentielle il y à ces
manifestations est ce que c'est
finalement pas une épine du pied dans
dans celle de pour le président de la
république emmanuel macron qui essaye un
petit peu de remobiliser ses troupes
aujourd'hui
le président avait 8 pensent aujourd'hui
vrai sens qu'il ya une demande d'ordre
d'autorité de stabilité qui est exprimé
par le chante électoral qui est le sien
et qui le socle électoral qui juste à
présence est susceptible de se mobiliser
peut-être de la manière la plus at il
donc l'analyse qu'il fait c'est que ce
mouvement loin de le contraindre est un
mouvement qui pourrait lui profiter
alors c'est une analyse qui est beau ce
qu'elle vaut en l'occurrence et seul
l'avenir le dira si son daniels et sur
l'analyse est fondée pas notre cas c'est
le socle stratégique qui est le sien à
ce stade d'autant plus qu'ils profitent
d'un shampooing équipe qui jusqu'à
présent n'est pas parvenu à faire
émerger des candidatures qui sont des
candidatures considérées comme crédibles
ou des candidatures d'alternative donc
lorsque politique d' emmanuel macron se
nourrit à la fois du désinvestissement
civique lé d'un grand nombre de nos
citoyens et de ses collègues qui sont
certes en effet forte sur le terrain
mais qui ne parviennent pas forcément à
s'agréger autour d'une offre politique
qui soit en mesure aujourd'hui de
compliments c'est emmanuel macron alors
on verra bien ce qui va se passer dans
les mois qui viennent parce qu on est
encore très loin et très proche à la
fois de l'élection présidentielle et que
tous les pronostics on a fait jusqu'à
présent des élections présidentielles a
dit moi quelles que soient les élections
qu'on y d'anciennes de ces dernières
années ont été en général infirmée par
le résultat d une ode à loïc bonnet ce
sera le mot de la fin aujourd'hui vous
êtes dans le monde du spectacle je parle
aussi pour le monde de la culture
comment est-ce qu'on s'organise est-ce
qu'on s'organise au jour le jour mois
par mois comment est ce que vous voyez
est les mois qui arrivent à la proche
aussi de cette élection présidentielle
vous savez on n'a pas choisi dans la
culture et dans le théâtre on n'a pas le
choix que de voir
mois par mois pas jour par jour nous il
faut qu'on vend des places bien en amont
moi aujourd'hui j'ai des spectacles tous
les jours pratiquement de maintenant
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle donc et ce qui est
encourageant c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
gens réussissent de nouveau à se
projeter ils achètent des places pour le
mois d'octobre mois de novembre le mois
de décembre le pire et c'est on l'a déjà
dit plusieurs fois c'est le stop and go
comme on a vécu depuis un an et demi
c'est à dire nous ouvrir puis nous
refermer ça veut dire décalé des
spectacles rembourser des gens gérer les
40000 places que vous avez vendu c'est
un enfer pour tout le monde et moi je
pense à mes collègues des l'événementiel
des mariages des concerts debout qui
n'ont pas vraiment repris encore il ya
tout un pan de cette économie qui n'a
pas repris il faut le dire moi j'ai une
petite salle j'ai de la chance j'ai
moins de 100 places on a repris mais si
on les très grosses salles ils n'ont pas
repris encore donc on est obligé de se
projeter loin et et il force est de
constater que ce pass sanitaire permet
cette projection au matin avec les une
certaine ont été mis en place l'oit
bonnet on vous souhaite plein de
spectacles pour les mois qui arrivent je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association des théâtres privés en
région arnaud benetti aussi merci
d'avoir été avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire merci monsieur